Ethan's,
the Gal says,
how do you boost your confidence?
Talking to people and get rid of the paranoid that people hate you and don't say
like you and think you're trash.
That's how I feel.
Okay,
well the first thing is,
um,
okay.
Let me tell you a little bit about courage.
No,
a little bit about trust.
Sorry.
When you're a naive person,
you trust people because you think that people are good and then maybe someone
comes along and hurts you and you think,
oh no,
people aren't good.
I can't trust anyone.
And then maybe you're paranoid.
You think that people hate you and don't like you and think your trash and so
forth.
You don't trust people.
But then you figure out,
Jesus,
this whole not trusting people isn't working out very well because now I can't
get anywhere.
And,
and if I ever do meet someone who's trustworthy and I don't trust them,
then they're not going to get an opportunity to show me that they're
trustworthy.
And so then what happens is that you replace naive trust with courageous trust,
and you put yourself out there despite the fact that people might hate you and
don't like you and think you're trash.
You know?
So
the other thing I would say that's more practical,
Ethan,
I think you'd find that you only think that when you run away,
my suspicions are if you went out and talked to people,
like you'd have to have something to talk about,
you know,
but if you went out and talked to people,
you'd find that those thoughts only bothered you for about 10 to 15 minutes and
then you would get over them.
You know,
a lot of that's a high neuroticism.
And,
and that's,
uh,
that in the big five aspect scale,
that's withdrawal.
You're experiencing a lot of withdrawal related negative emotions,
anticipatory anxiety.
And the best way to overcome that is to not avoid.
So if you find yourself avoiding social situations,
then you have to formulate a plan to stop doing that.
And then over time your confidence will be boosted.